la quoi ressemble la page d'accueil de
l'administrateur du compte youtube de la
première chaîne de télévision de la
république autoproclamée de donetsk
complètement vide et pour cause youtube
il a purement et simplement supprimé
il a été supprimé définitivement pour
toujours sans aucun avertissement il n'y
a pas eu d'accusations mais à proprement
parler aucune accusation était même
possible je pense du point de vue du
respect des règles parce que nous
faisons notre travail je dirais en nous
basant sur les fondements classiques du
journalisme d'information
donc il n'y a pas eu de violation
flagrante de notre part
après cette décision était malgré tout
plus ou moins attendue étant donné ce
qui est arrivé aux autres organes
d'information des deux républiques
autoproclamées
le fait est que cette situation était en
partie déjà prévisibles pour nous nous
avons prévu cette situation avant cela
il ya eu des blocages d'autres
ressources des républiques populaires de
donetsk de lougansk
donc nous continuerons à informer les
habitants de la rpd et de la communauté
internationale dans son ensemble comme
nous le faisions jusqu'à présent
au final dans un sens la direction de la
chaîne prend cette décision de youtube
comme une certaine reconnaissance de
leur travail en effet ce journaliste
documente la guerre telle qu'elle est
vécue dans le donbass et cela n'a pas
l'air de plaire à tout le monde
c'est une purge des ressources
d'information de la république qui est
en cours et la chaîne pervy reste public
en ski et la chaîne phare à l'heure
actuelle on voit que dans les conditions
de guerre de l'information chacun doit
choisir son camp j'ai toujours dit y
compris à mes employés que c'est
beaucoup plus facile pour nous de
travailler parce qu'on parle vraiment de
ce qui se passe ici si on nous croit ou
non à en juger par les résultats on nous
croit nous avons donc une certaine
influence
et même bière de l'information cyber
influences telles sont les termes
utilisés pour désigner les mesures
prises par certains acteurs pour faire
taire les voix dissonantes et bien
souvent au final la liberté de la presse
et la pluralité de l'information en sont
les premières victimes